empecemos por ver otra vez lo que
hicimos en el último vídeo pero de una
forma un poquito más visual entonces
tenemos por aquí un rectángulo digamos
que este es el conjunto de todos los
posibles resultados del experimento
anterior donde teníamos una urna y en la
urna teníamos nueve monedas normales
pero teníamos una moneda que tenía sólo
de los dos lados o sea era una moneda
con dos soles y lo que hacíamos era
escoger aleatoriamente una de esas
monedas y sin ver qué tipo de moneda es
o sea si es una moneda normal o la
moneda de los dos soles tomábamos esa
moneda y hacíamos cinco volados y nos
estábamos preguntando por cuál es la
probabilidad de que estos cinco lados
hayan salido en sol y bueno de hecho
hicimos unos cálculos y la encontramos y
ahora lo que vamos a hacer es lo mismo
por una forma más visual
ok tenemos aquí al conjunto de todos los
posibles resultados por ejemplo por aquí
hay un punto
qué significa el hecho de que hayamos
tomado una moneda normal y hayamos
sacado sol allí la sol águila sol en los
cinco volados y por aquí hay otro
puntito que representa el hecho de que
hayamos tomado la moneda de los dos
soles y hayan salido soles en cada uno
de los volados y así pero bueno el
chiste es que este es nuestro espacio de
posibles resultados y vamos a suponer
que tiene un área igual a 1 que estos
son todos los resultados todos
los posibles posibles
los resultados azul
y además su área estamos suponiendo que
me ve uno bueno y ahora teníamos la urna
con todas las monedas allá adentro y
sacábamos una moneda pero como había
nueve monedas normales y una moneda que
tiene dos soles entonces la probabilidad
de que hayamos tomado la moneda que
tiene dos soles es 11º entonces llegamos
aquí está la mitad por aquí está un
cuarto por aquí está un octavo entonces
más o menos digo en el dibujo no tenemos
que ser exactos esta área de aquí
es el área en el que se encuentran todos
los puntitos que representan a los
posibles resultados en los que sacamos a
la moneda de dos soles de la urna de
gemelas relleno entonces esta área es en
la que sacamos a los dos soles por otro
lado toda esta otra área es el área en
el que de la urna sacamos una moneda
normal todo este cuadrado
que voy a llenar de azul es el área en
el que sacamos alguna moneda
ahora mal a ver entonces esta área
amarilla mide la probabilidad de sacar a
la moneda que tiene dos soles que es un
décimo y esta otra área mide la
probabilidad de sacar una moneda normal
que es 9 decimos bueno pero hay otras
áreas que nos interesan por ejemplo
tenemos que poner por aquí una región
adentro de la región en la que sacamos
una moneda en normal pero esta es una
región en la que no sólo sacamos una
moneda normal sino que además a la hora
de tirar los cinco volados sacamos cinco
soles entonces toda esta región de aquí
es la región de la moneda normal
donde salieron 5 soles ahora si se
acuerdan una vez que uno tiene una
moneda normal o sea que está viviendo en
este territorio la probabilidad de sacar
cinco soles es 1 entre 32 entonces esta
área queremos que sea 132 a la parte del
área normal a ver voy a borrar esto
porque me estorba
otra forma de describir a los puntos que
están en este conjunto es escribir n de
que nos salió una moneda normal
intersección 5 soles
ok donde este símbolo significa
intersección es el símbolo de la
intersección de dos conjuntos y para
recordar que significa a mí me gusta
imaginar una y por acá que nos dice que
para que un punto esté por aquí tiene
que suceder esta condición
esta otra condición pero bueno
ahora para sacar esta área podemos ver
que pues este subconjunto habíamos dicho
que es una 32 a la parte del rectángulo
azul porque hay entonces su área va a
ser 1 entre 32 por el área del
rectángulo azul porque es una 32 aparte
del rectángulo azul pero el rectángulo
azul tiene un área de 9 decimos 9
decimos bueno pero hay otra forma muy
interesante de interpretar a esta área y
esa es que esté un 90 y 32 pues es la
probabilidad de obtener 5 soles dado que
estamos lanzando una moneda normal
este 9 decimos que tenemos por aquí es
igual a la probabilidad de obtener una
moneda normal
una moneda normal ahora otra forma de
interpretar a esta área es como la
probabilidad
de que se cumplen las dos condiciones
que están restringiendo quienes entran
dentro de este conjunto y quienes no o
sea la probabilidad de obtener una
moneda normal
que no salgan cinco soles entonces lo
que acabamos de demostrar con estas
áreas es que esta probabilidad es igual
a esta multiplicación de probabilidades
y pues viceversa entonces la
probabilidad de obtener una moneda
normal y que no salgan cinco soles
es igual a esta área naranja que a su
vez es igual a la probabilidad
condicional de que no salgan 5 soles
dado que sacamos una moneda normal por
la probabilidad de sacar una moneda
normal la probabilidad de sacar una
moneda normal
ok grábense esta fórmula porque es muy
útil siempre que estamos hablando de
probabilidades
ok tenemos aquí un conjunto naranja que
está contenido en otro conjunto azul y
entonces la probabilidad de que salga
algún resultado que se encuentre en este
conjunto o sea la probabilidad de que
nos salga una moneda normal y cinco
soles en los volados es igual al
porcentaje de área que ocupa este
conjunto naranja con respecto al
conjunto azul que
es esta probabilidad condicional por el
área total del conjunto azul que es esta
probabilidad de aquí y aquí ya habíamos
hecho las cuentas y nos quede 9 entre
320 en este rectángulo naranja tiene un
área de 9 entre 320 bueno y de este lado
amarillo que cuál es el subconjunto en
el que salen 5 soles aunque hay queremos
encontrar cuál es el área o la
probabilidad de que nos salga una moneda
con 2 soles
déjenme borrar esa y saquemos 5 soles en
los volados pues podemos hacer un
razonamiento análogo al que hicimos aquí
y a lo que vamos a llegar es que esto es
igual a la probabilidad de sacar 5 soles
dado que estamos lanzando una moneda que
tiene dos soles por la probabilidad de
haber sacado a la moneda que tiene dos
soles aunque ahí está exactamente el
mismo razonamiento la otra pregunta es
qué porción de este rectángulo amarillo
es el que tengo que dibujar y bueno pues
resulta que si tengo dos soles entonces
todos los volados van a salir como soles
entonces obviamente para cualquier
resultado que esté aquí en el área en el
que sacamos una moneda que tiene dos
soles a la hora de tirar cinco volados
nos van a salir cinco soles entonces
todos estos resultados que están en el
área amarilla también están en el área
en el que número uno salen dos soles
pero número dos salen cinco soles en los
cinco volados así es que satisfacen
estas dos condiciones y pertenecen al
área que queremos medir aquí ahora por
otro lado si lo queremos ver
analíticamente cuál es la probabilidad
de que salgan cinco soles dado que
tenemos a la moneda que tiene
sol es el mismo razonamiento que
acabamos de hacer nos dice que esta área
mide 1 o sea mide el 100% pero pues este
rectángulo rosa que está dentro del
rectángulo amarillo entonces mide el
100% del rectángulo amarillo pero el
rectángulo amarillo mide un décimo así
es que el rectángulo rosa también mide
un décimo pero entonces y ahora queremos
calcular la probabilidad de que no
salgan 5 soles
y no nos importa si sacamos una moneda
normal o una moneda que tiene dos soles
entonces lo que tenemos que hacer es
calcular esta área de aquí toda esta
área pero pues eso es muy fácil no lo
único que tenemos que hacer es sumar
estas dos áreas entonces esto es igual a
ver aquí lo habíamos calculado 9 entre
320 que es el área del rectángulo
naranja más el área del rectángulo rosa
que es 1 entre 10 1 entre 10 que
calculamos muy bien en el vídeo pasado
aquí nada más lo estamos haciendo con
áreas pero bueno esto también lo podemos
escribir como la probabilidad de que nos
salga una moneda normal y nos salgan
5 soles
más la probabilidad de que nos salga una
moneda con dos soles y saquemos cinco
soles muy bien entonces ya resolvimos el
problema de otra forma pero vamos a la
pregunta tan interesante que estábamos
haciendo al final del otro vídeo para lo
cual necesitamos más espacio
a ver lo tenía yo porque bien entonces
queríamos preguntarnos cuál es la
probabilidad de que hayamos sacado la
moneda que tiene dos soles dado que
sacamos cinco soles en cinco volados y
bueno pusimos aquí una probabilidad muy
parecida para comparar para que no te
vayas a confundir y vayas a creer que
son lo mismo a ver cuál es la diferencia
entre estas dos aquí nosotros sabemos
que tenemos a la moneda que tiene dos
soles y nos estamos preguntando cuál es
la probabilidad de sacar cinco soles
seguidos en cinco volados y pues como la
moneda solo puede sacar soles entonces
sabemos que esa probabilidad es 1 pero
de este lado nosotros lo que sabemos es
que tomamos una moneda de la urna y no
vimos cuál era pero a la hora de tirar
cinco volados nos salieron cinco soles
aquí esto de aquí es lo que sí sabemos
que nos salieron cinco soles
ahora de lo que queremos sacar la
probabilidad sabiendo esto
de si la moneda con la que estamos
lanzando los volados es la que tiene
únicamente soles y bueno para resolver
esto va a ser muy analítico y lo primero
que vamos a hacer es sacar toda la
información que ya tenemos por el
momento las probabilidades que ya
sabemos cómo calcular son por ejemplo la
probabilidad de que salgan cinco soles
dado que tenemos a la moneda que tiene
dos soles o por ejemplo la probabilidad
de que hayamos tomado la moneda que
tiene dos soles y bueno hace unos
cuantos minutos vimos cómo sacar la
probabilidad de que hayamos sacado cinco
soles
y tengamos la moneda que tiene
únicamente dos soles si hecho vimos que
era igual a la multiplicación de estas
dos probabilidades en general cuando
tenemos dos condiciones a las que les
podemos llamar a y b tenemos que la
probabilidad de que suceda a y suceda b
es igual a la probabilidad de que suceda
a dado que ya sabemos qué sucedió ve por
la probabilidad de que suceda ve ok esto
es algo que demostramos arriba con las
áreas para este ejemplo en específico
pero qué sucede para cualesquiera
condiciones ahí ve que haya estas
condiciones de hecho les llamamos
eventos pero además aquí podemos
aprovechar que la intersección de dos
conjuntos es algo simétrico eso quiere
decir que la probabilidad de la
intersección b es igual a la
probabilidad de
intersección pues porque son el mismo
conjunto y entonces podemos volver a
aplicar esta fórmula pero con la ve y la
ha cambiado de lugar y lo que nos queda
es la probabilidad de b dado a por la
probabilidad de a haber entonces éste
que es exactamente este es igualito a
este y por lo tanto este lado es
igualito a este lado a ver vamos a
volver a escribir la probabilidad de ha
dado b por la probabilidad de p eso es
esto de aquí es igual a la probabilidad
de b dado a por la probabilidad de a y
entonces si queremos digamos despejar
alguna de estas dos probabilidades
condicionales lo único que tenemos que
hacer es pasar dividiendo a la
probabilidad de a la probabilidad de b
dependiendo de qué es lo que queramos
siempre y cuando es
probabilidades en distintas de cero eso
es muy importante pero bueno entonces
digamos que queremos esta probabilidad
así es que dividimos entre esta
probabilidad de los dos lados y lo que
nos queda es la probabilidad de ha dado
ve por la probabilidad de b por la
probabilidad de b entre la probabilidad
de a entre la probabilidad de a es igual
a la probabilidad de vedado a
probabilidad de p lado
y esta fórmula de aquí se conoce como la
fórmula
valles y es muy importante siempre que
esté trabajando con probabilidades
condicionales y bueno por supuesto que
vamos a usar esta fórmula para encontrar
esta probabilidad aquella esta
probabilidad va a ser lo equivalente a
esta de aquí y de este lado pues ya
tenemos a todas las probabilidades esta
va a ser esta y ésta también la
conocemos es la probabilidad de obtener
una moneda normal si es que te veo en el
próximo vídeo